We were right. All of our critics were wrong. I'll put my premise out there. The premise is that if you want to get to the best performance or even the like just correctness or performance, whichever one, if you want to get there in the most token efficient way possible, higher level abstractions, higher level languages, and in particular functional languages, I suspect I'm starting to get early data that indicates that they are the superior option. Like, I think that the ideal programming language for some class of tasks, maybe a large class of tasks, is probably something that looks a lot more like APL than anything else. And like to APL also, you know, I always make funny, you Connor, that it's so, like,
我们是对的。所有的批评者都是错的。我先抛出我的观点。这个观点是，如果你想获得最佳性能，甚至是哪怕仅仅是正确性还是性能（无论哪个），如果你想以最节省 Token 的方式达到这个目标，更高层次的抽象、更高层次的语言，特别是函数式语言——我怀疑，而且我开始看到一些早期数据表明——它们是更优的选择。我觉得，对于某类任务（也许是很大一类任务）来说，理想的编程语言可能看起来比其他任何语言都更像 APL。而且就像 APL 一样，你知道的，我总是开玩笑说，康纳，它太……
compact and, like, symbol heavy, but, like, that's also very token efficient. So, so I think, I think that I think you may be justified. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 293 recorded on July 2nd, 20206. My name is Connor. Today with my co-hosts, we chat about AI versus abstractions, the ideal language for LLMs to target and more. It is, it is, I'll give it to an American. It's 99 degrees out, and it's supposed to feel like 111, with 99 degrees and, you Canadian. No, not in dollars. It gave me 99 degrees in dollars.
紧凑，而且充满了各种符号，但这也非常节省 Token。所以，所以我觉得，我觉得你的做法可能是对的。欢迎收看第 293 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2026 年 7 月 2 日。我是康纳。今天我和我的联席主持人们将一起探讨 AI 与抽象、LLM 的目标理想语言等话题。外面温度是 99 度（我入乡随俗用华氏度），体感温度应该是 111 度，而且……等一下，你是加拿大人。不，不是用加元。它给我的温度是 99 度。
So it's 37 Celsius. The sea stands for Canada. But it feels like, it feels like 43 Celsius outside right now. So I'm not leaving, I'm not leaving the, uh, the apartment for a while. Yeah, it's, it is, it feels the same. in Toronto, but it's only 32, which converted to Fahrenheit is 89.6 feels like 109.4. Yesterday, I didn't go for a run because it was, it felt like 46, and I hadn't gone for a run the day before. Anyways, I think it was like two or three days in a row, but then today I was like, it's too much. I got to go for a run. And it was pretty bad. I'd like to say that it wasn't that hot, but it was my heart rate. I was just running like jogging, five and a half minute pace per
所以也就是 37 摄氏度。C 代表加拿大（Canada）。但现在外面的体感温度感觉像 43 摄氏度。所以我不会离开，我一会儿不会离开我的公寓。对，它，感觉是一样的。在多伦多也是这样，但那里只有 32 度，换算成华氏度是 89.6 度，体感温度是 109.4 度。昨天我没有去跑步，因为感觉有 46 度那么热，而且前一天我也没有去跑步。总之，好像连续两三天都是这样，但今天我想：这也太热了。我必须得去跑步。结果跑得挺惨的。我想说其实没那么热，但我的心率……我当时只是在慢跑，配速大概是每公里五分半钟，
kilometer, which is definitely not that fast for me. And my heart rate was at 165, which is way too high for running that slow. So I walked a bit and stay safe, folks, stay hydrated. I think I lost about five pounds worth of sweat on a 13 kilometer run, which is ridiculous. Anyways, weather's hot. I was supposed to go for a run today with Eddie. You know Eddie, right? I do not know Eddie. Who's Eddie?
对我的水平来说这绝对不算快。但我的心率达到了 165，对于这么慢的跑步来说实在太高了。所以我走了一会儿。各位，注意安全，多喝水。我觉得我跑了 13 公里，出的汗大概有 5 磅重，这太离谱了。总之，天气很热。我本来今天打算和埃迪一起去跑步。你认识埃迪吧？我不认识埃迪。埃迪是谁？
Eddie, Nolan? He's one of the C++ people down in New York. Anyways, we were supposed to go for a run today. And then he just texted me and he's like, it's too hot. Maybe we can take a rain check. And I was like, okay, all right. I guess we can do that. Oh, man, what a week.
埃迪·诺兰（Eddie Nolan）？他是纽约那边玩 C++ 的其中一位。总之，我们本来今天打算去跑步的。然后他发短信给我说，天气太热了。也许我们可以改天再约。我就回说，好吧，好吧。我想也只能这样了。哦，天哪，真是糟糕的一周。
What a week. I'm back in the U.S. for like two weeks, then we're going back to Europe for more stuff. Did you just get back from Europe? This is just like, I feel like the last three months have been like a year. Hang on my internet's still being really crappy. Yeah, this is much better. It's crazy that like my, I'm getting like one,
真是糟糕的一周。我回美国待了两周左右，然后又要回欧洲去处理一些事情。你刚从欧洲回来吗？这感觉就像……我觉得过去三个月就像过了一年一样。等等，我的网络还是很烂。对，这样好多了。太疯狂了，我的……
I'm barely getting one megavit per second from my home Wi-Fi right now. Holy F, that's so slow. Yeah, I know. There's something's got to be, it's the heat, it's the heat. The Verizon can't take the heat. Maybe one day I'll tell the story of how I spent a weekend trying to Jerry Rig with a Gigahub 2.0 Bell kit, a mesh network with like three different nodes and a bunch of stuff. Anyways, I didn't know what I was doing.
我的家庭 Wi-Fi 现在每秒连一兆比特都勉强达到。我靠，太慢了。对，我知道。肯定有什么问题，是天气原因，是天气原因。Verizon 扛不住这酷暑。也许有一天我会讲讲我是怎么花了一个周末的时间，试图用一个 2.0 版本的贝尔吉加网关（Gigahub 2.0 Bell kit），拼凑出一个包含三个不同节点和一堆东西的网格网络的。总之，我当时根本不知道自己在干什么。
And it was only like, I think it was Claude. It was Opus 3.7 or 4.0. Oh, this is recent. And yeah, it was back in September. And it took me a while. But oh boy, oh boy, once I got that kitten purring, who it is. And I also, that was the weekend I discovered that Ethernet cables,
当时大概是……我觉得是 Claude。那是 Opus 3.7 或者是 4.0。哦，这是最近的事。对，那是去年九月。花了我好一阵子。但是，天哪，天哪，一旦我把那台机器调教得像小猫一样呼噜呼噜作响时，那感觉绝了。而且我也就是在那天周末发现，网线这东西……
I mean, why I didn't think that, I guess I just never had fast enough internet for the cable to make a difference. But like at some point, I just had like, you know how you have that basket of like HDMI cables and Ethernet cables and a bunch of cables that like 90% you'll never use, but you don't throw stuff? You just throw it in like a box in case you need it one. day. Anyways, I needed a couple different
我是说，为什么我以前没想到呢？我想我大概只是以前从来没有过足够快的网络，所以网线好坏根本没区别。但有那么一刻，我手头有……你知道你平时会有一个装满 HDMI 线、网线以及一堆线材的篮子吗？其中 90% 你永远都不会用，但你又舍不得扔？你只会把它们扔进一个盒子里，万一哪天能派上用场呢。总之，我当时需要几根不同的
Ethernet cables and I was just like, how come, because I think we signed up for 3 gigabit internet. It wasn't the fastest, but I think it was like the second fastest. Anyways, and like I wasn't getting anywhere close to it. And then AI's like, well, show me your cable. And then I was like, nah, that's not going to cut it. You need to
网线，然后我就在想，为什么……因为我觉得我们申请的是 3 吉比特的宽带。虽然不是最快的，但我想也是第二快的。总之，我当时网速根本达不到那个标准。然后 AI 就说：“让我看看你的网线。”接着我就想：得了吧，这根本不行。你需要
go order a better cable. And I was like, the cable? I was like, I paid for the internet. Isn't that it? Well, I'm sure like 80% of our audience is like, wow, this guy doesn't know anything. Yeah, I was going to, I was going to say like before you started talking about internet, Ethernet Cables, I was going to say,
去订购一根更好的网线。我就想：“网线？我花钱买的难道不就是宽带吗？难道不这就够了吗？”好吧，我敢肯定我们大约 80% 的听众现在都在想：哇，这家伙什么都不懂。对，我正要说……在你开始谈论网络和网线之前，我本来想说的是，
this is going to be a, Connor is solely a software person type of story. I used to put together racks for our lab when I was at LSU. So I've been there, had to deal with that. Yeah. Oh, God, what was I,
这将会是一个“康纳完全是个纯软件人才”类型的故事。我在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）的时候，曾亲手为我们的实验室组装过机架。所以我有过这方面的经历，不得不去处理那些东西。噢，天哪，我刚才说到哪儿了？
what was I said to say? What were you just? We were talking about heat internet. Oh, yeah, yeah. I was going to tell a great price story. Perfect. Which is when I moved to Berkeley, after I was in Louisiana, I moved to Berkeley, and it's really tough to find an apartment in Berkeley.
我刚才说到哪儿了？我们刚才在聊热浪和网络。哦，对，对。我本来要讲一个很棒的布莱斯故事。完美。也就是当我搬到伯克利的时候，在离开路易斯安那州之后，我搬到了伯克利，要在伯克利找一套公寓真的很难。
And I'm staying with my step-step-sister. That is my stepfather's ex-wife's new husband's daughter. So her and I share step-siblings. So she's my step-step-sister. Wait, say that again. It's your step-fathers' ex-wife's... ex-wife's... New husband's daughter.
当时我和我的“继继姐”住在一起。那是我的继父的前妻的新丈夫的女儿。所以她和我共享继亲关系。所以她是我的“继继姐”。等等，再说一遍。那是你继父的……前妻的……新丈夫的女儿。
So my stepfather's ex-wife's daughter-in-law. Well, Bryce is just frozen. So you got the connection, hopefully. I think I understand it now. You did freeze in the middle of that, but I'll stitch it together. Yeah. Anyway, so I'm staying with her. I'm trying to find a place to live.
所以是我继父的前妻的儿媳妇……好吧，布莱斯卡住不动了。所以你大概听懂了，希望如此。我想我现在明白了。你在中间确实卡顿了一下，但我会把它拼凑起来的。对，总之，我和她住在一起。我当时在找一个住处。
And eventually, there's just like only really one place that's like in my... my price range and that like is still available. And so I just like, I go and I see it and then I sort of sign up without really like looking at it that deeply. And there were a couple of things that I didn't think to ask whether they had because I was moving from Louisiana. And so in Louisiana, everywhere has AC. It's just like you have to have air conditioning in Louisiana. So like I never even thought to ask, does this apartment have air conditioning? The apartment had no air conditioning.
最后，真的只有那么一个地方在我的预算范围内，而且还在招租。所以我就去看了看，然后基本上没怎么深入考察就签约了。当时有几件事我没想到要问他们有没有，因为我是从路易斯安那州搬过来的。在路易斯安那州，到处都有空调。在路易斯安那州，你必须得有空调。所以，我甚至从来没想过要问：这间公寓有空调吗？这间公寓没有空调。
It also had no wash dryer in the unit, and it had no dishwasher, all of which I suffered with for three years. And then I swore I would never be in another apartment without all three of those things. And the day I was moving, so I used to stay at Berkeley Lab in the summers until like 8 p.m. Because it would be too hot to go home. And there was like no cross ventilation. And the day I was moving out of that apartment, there was like this epic California heat wave. it was like 110 degrees in Berkeley or something.
它也没有独立洗衣烘干机，也没有洗碗机，所有这些我都忍受了三年。然后我发誓，我再也不会住进一间不同时具备这三样东西的公寓了。就在我搬家的那天——我以前夏天总是在伯克利实验室待到晚上 8 点，因为家里太热根本没法呆，而且那里也没有对流风——在我搬出那间公寓的那天，加州发生了历史性的热浪。伯克利的温度好像达到了 110 华氏度（约 43.3 摄氏度）左右。
And so I'm here in my apartment completely naked, packing up all my stuff because it's so hot. You can't even put clothes on. Anyways, that's the bright story. Well, I caught like 90% of that because you kept cutting out. We'll have to see whether we leave in the part where we talk about you being naked, because I'm not sure how many listeners we're going to lose over that, even if it's just an audio description. and I'm running speed tests on my phone to see what's going on with the internet. It's starting to come back.
所以我当时光着身子待在公寓里，打包我所有的东西，因为实在太热了，根本没法穿衣服。总之，这就是布莱斯的故事。好吧，我大概听懂了 90%，因为你一直在断断续续。我们得看看等下剪辑时要不要保留你光着身子的这段，因为我不确定有多少听众会因此而流失，哪怕这只是纯音频描述。我正在手机上运行测速，看看网络到底怎么了。网速开始恢复了。
All right. And I'll listen to the full story upon editing it. And I guess the listener won't hear the drops because they'll be listening to the locally recorded stuff. Anyways, you got a bright story. The internet is on. I may have to, I think we're going to, let's turn off our, let's turn off our video. All right, we're turning off the video, talking into the void. and all right we started off with a bright story a little bit of weather a little bit of internet woes
好的。剪辑的时候我会把完整的故事听一遍。我想听众也不会听到中断的地方，因为他们听到的是本地录制的内容。总之，你讲了个布莱斯的故事。网速恢复了。我可能得……我觉得我们要把视频关掉，让我们关掉视频。好吧，我们正在关掉视频，对着虚空讲话。好吧，我们以一个布莱斯的故事开场，聊了点天气，还有点网络故障。
what else is new for the listener this is a uh if you're wondering why is this episode so chaotic or why is it so much more chaotic than usual it is july second happy Canada day and happy early America day what do you guys say happy 4th of july and we are supposed to release an episode tomorrow. And it's, sir, sir, it's America's 250th anniversary. Show some respect. No, that's okay. That's okay.
对于听众来说，还有什么新鲜事呢？这是一个……如果你在想为什么这期节目这么混乱，或者为什么比平时混乱得多，今天是 7 月 2 日。加拿大日快乐，美国独立日提前快乐！你们觉得呢？国庆节快乐！我们本该在明天发布一期节目。而且，先生，先生，今天是美国建国 250 周年。表现出一点尊重吧。不，没关系。没关系。
I mean, America's going through it. You guys can't even, like, clean your ponds or lakes or whatever mirror pools correctly without wasting a bunch of money. And although I will say, I've heard some very heartwarming stories. I listen to the daily this Sunday, or was it this past Sunday? one of the more recent dailies was talking about the World Cup and different, like, fans from different countries visiting. And apparently, like, there's a city outside of Kansas City, which a friend of the pod, Jared Hobrock, who was on a couple times talking about Thrust and Friends. He'll know this city.
我是说，美国现在正经历着各种状况。你们甚至连自己的池塘、湖泊或各种倒影池都无法正确清理，白白浪费了一大笔钱。不过话又说回来，我确实听到了一些非常暖心的故事。我这个星期天听了《The Daily》（纽约时报播客），或者说是上个星期天？最近几期的其中一期在谈论世界杯以及来自不同国家的球迷的造访。显然，在堪萨斯城郊外有一个城市——本播客的老朋友杰拉德·霍布拉克（Jared Hobrock）曾几次上节目谈论 Thrust and Friends，他会知道这个城市的。
I don't know of it. I only heard about it in the podcast. There's a city called Lawrence outside of Kansas City. I think I've got that right. And apparently it's hosting the country of Algeria. Algeria. And anyway, very heartwarming to see the people of America. Because apparently they got the local college marching band to like welcome them off the
我不知道这个城市。我只在播客里听说过。堪萨斯城郊外有一个叫劳伦斯（Lawrence）的城市。我想我没记错名字。显然它正在接待阿尔及利亚国家队。阿尔及利亚。不管怎样，看到美国人民这样做真的很暖心。因为显然他们找了当地大学的军乐队去机场迎接阿尔及利亚代表团，
plane and play them Algeria National Anthem. And like all of the locals, whenever they see the Algeria soccer players, they're always cheering for them. And apparently they're like rooting for, obviously they're rooting for USA as well. But apparently they're also rooting for Algeria. Anyways, so, you know, there's some positive stuff about America. So I have some irony. for you. What's that? I was
并演奏了阿尔及利亚国歌。而且所有的当地人，每当他们看到阿尔及利亚的足球运动员时，都会为他们欢呼。显然他们不仅在为美国队加油，很明显他们也在为美国队加油，但显然他们同时也在为阿尔及利亚加油。总之，你知道的，关于美国也有一些积极的一面。所以我有一个讽刺性的经历要分享给你。
logging in. You're going to just love this. I'm logging into my Verizon account and it asked me a security question. And the security question is who's your best buddy? And can you guess what the security answer was? It was you, Connor. You were the security answer. I can't
是什么？我刚才在登录。你绝对会爱上这个。我正在登录我的 Verizon 账户，它问了我一个安全问题。安全问题是：你最好的哥们是谁？你能猜到安全答案是什么吗？就是你，康纳。你就是那个安全答案。我甚至
even remember when I would have set this up. That's heartwarming as well. Maybe they'll call this the heartwarming episode. Oh, man. Oh, yes. Anyway, let me finish the preamble, though. So this is all to say, I don't even remember how I started talking about America Day. Oh, right, I was just saying the date.
记不清自己是什么时候设置这个的了。这也太暖心了。也许他们会把这期节目叫做“暖心之期”。天哪。哦，对了。不管怎样，让我先把开场白说完。所以这一切都是在说，我甚至不记得我是怎么开始聊起美国日的。哦，对，我刚才只是在说日期。
It's July 2nd. You're listening to this sometime after July 3rd, but this episode is dropping July 3rd. And I only like this morning, because it's been such a chaotic last week and a half. I was in Ireland for a wedding and for a few days off. And then when I got back, my sister was visiting me from Calgary with her two kids, one's three and a half, one's one and a half. and they're a handful. Anyway, so it was like we landed.
今天是 7 月 2 日。你们听到这期节目的时候应该是在 7 月 3 日之后了，但这期节目会在 7 月 3 日发布。我直到今天早上才意识到这一点，因为过去一个半星期实在太混乱了。我去爱尔兰参加了一个婚礼，顺便放了几天假。然后我一回来，我姐姐就带着她的两个孩子从卡尔加里来看我，一个三岁半，一个一岁半。
We had a couple hours, then they were staying with us. And oh yeah, this was the weekend where you wanted to crash, but I wasn't in town. And then they only just left. And anyways,
他们俩简直是个大麻烦。总之，就像是我们刚落地，有几个小时的空闲，然后他们就住进我们家了。哦，对了，这就是那个你想崩溃的周末，但我当时不在城里。然后他们刚刚离开。总之，
and I realized, oh yeah, tomorrow I have to edit a podcast. And then like 10 seconds later was like, wait a second, I don't have any content to edit. Oh, well, I, boy, do I have content for you.
我突然意识到，哦，对了，明天我得剪辑一期播客。然后大约 10 秒钟后我反应过来：等一下，我根本没有任何素材可以剪辑。哦，好吧，天哪，我这里正好有的是素材。
And then I DMed Bryce and was like, hey, And Bryce, both of us are very busy. So the odds that we have like a free slot for 30 minutes are low. So I thought it was going to end up being one of these. Like I talk into the recorder by myself for 10 minutes and recommend a couple podcasts. But Bryce magically was free. That's like 10 minutes out of the way or it says 16 on my audacity.
然后我给布莱斯发私信说：“嘿……”布莱斯和我都很忙。所以我们俩能腾出 30 分钟空档的几率很低。所以我以为最后会变成这样：我自己对着录音机自言自语 10 分钟，然后推荐几档播客。但布莱斯神奇般地有空。这已经过去大约 10 分钟了，或者说我的 Audacity 显示是 16 分钟。
So anyways, now we're going to talk another 20 minutes about probably something AI related. You know, maybe it's going to be Codex. Although you're on Claude Code. I heard, I saw you got a hoodie on Twitter. I don't know where my hoodie is from OpenA. but I deserve a... Hang out, I gotta try connecting back to the Wi-Fi again because now my cell phone has no service.
不管怎样，现在我们要再聊 20 分钟左右，大概是关于 AI 相关的话题。你知道的，也许会是 Codex。虽然你在用 Claude Code。我听说，我看到你在推特上穿了一件连帽衫。我不知道我的 OpenAI 连帽衫放哪儿了，但我其实也配得上一件……等等，我得再试着连回 Wi-Fi，因为现在我的手机没信号了。
Okay, now that's like fine. All right, can you hear me now? Yeah, I can hear you. Okay. Anyways, yeah, that's, you know, messed up. Anyways, you said you've got stories for me, so I'm ready for them. No, I have a topic, which is,
好吧，现在差不多了。好了，现在能听到我说话吗？可以，我能听到。好吧。不管怎样，太糟糕了。总之，你刚才说你有故事要讲，所以我准备好听了。不，我有一个话题，那就是：
essentially, I think our entire life's work is vindicated. We were right, all of our... critics were wrong. And that is the premise of my story today, that I've, you know, been doing a lot of this agenic stuff for a couple months now, mostly focused on auto research. But the last week or so, I've come upon the question of programming language token economics, specifically like programming language token efficiency. And I'll put my premise out there. The premise is that, If you want to get to, you know, the best performance or even the, like, just correctness or performance, whichever one, if you want to get there in the most token efficient way possible, higher level abstractions, higher level languages, and in particular functional languages, I suspect I'm starting to get early data that indicates that they are the superior option. I think that the ideal programming language for some class of tasks, maybe a large class of tasks,
从本质上讲，我认为我们一生的工作得到了证实。我们是对的，我们所有的批评者都是错的。这就是我今天故事的前提，那就是，你知道的，我最近几个月一直在做很多这种智能体（agentic）相关的工作，主要集中在自动研究上。但在过去一周左右的时间里，我遇到了编程语言 Token 经济学的问题，特别是编程语言的 Token 效率。我先把我的观点摆出来。这个观点是：如果你想达到最佳性能，甚至是哪怕仅仅是正确性还是性能（无论哪个），如果你想以最节省 Token 的方式达到这个目标，更高层次的抽象、更高层次的语言，特别是函数式语言——我怀疑，而且我开始看到一些早期数据表明——它们是更优的选择。我觉得，对于某类任务（也许是很大一类任务）来说，理想的编程语言
is probably something that looks a lot more like APL than anything else. And like to APL also, you know, I always make funny, you Connor, that it's so like compact and like symbol heavy, but like that's also very token efficient. So I think, I think that I think you may be justified. And so the actual, the logic behind this argument is twofold. One, a higher level of abstractions means that more of the control of how the program gets lowered is decided by the compiler, the deterministic compiler, which is the cheaper thing, right, in comparison to, you know, spending tokens.
可能看起来比其他任何语言都更像 APL。而且就像 APL 一样，你知道的，我总是开玩笑说，康纳，它太紧凑了，而且符号很多，但这也是非常节省 Token 的。所以，我觉得，我觉得你的做法可能是支持的。所以，这个论点背后的逻辑其实有两个方面。第一，更高层级的抽象意味着程序如何被降解（lowered）的控制权，更多地交给了编译器——确定性的编译器，相比于消耗 Token，这是一种更省钱的方式。
So writing something in, you know, some high-level scripting language or something or, or, you know, something like modern C++, where it's going to be substantially shorter, substantially less code, substantially less time to develop than writing it all yourself in C. That's going to just be more, you know, efficient. And the other piece of this is around guardrails. So there's one, the question of abstraction layer. And there's the second question of guardrails. And these usually go hand in hands. And the premise here is that languages that have more guardrails where you catch errors early or where there's only really one correct way to write things, that they will be better for agents
所以，用某种高级脚本语言或者诸如现代 C++ 之类编写代码，会比你自己用 C 语言从头编写要短得多、代码量少得多、开发时间少得多。这本身就会更有效率。而这其中的另一个部分则关乎安全护栏（guardrails）。所以一个是抽象层级的问题，第二个则是安全护栏的问题。这两者通常是相辅相成的。这里的基本前提是：拥有更多安全护栏的语言，能够让你更早地发现错误，或者说编写代码只有一种真正正确的方式，这种语言对智能体（agents）会更好，
because agents will spend less time making mistakes and having to learn from those mistakes. So languages like Rust is the premise are better for agentic work. And I think that if all of this turns out to be true, then that just vindigates all of us, all of us who've advocated for abstractions and, you know, generic programming, functional programming, all these things that we talk about that the people of the world have given us a hard time about. Anyways, I wonder what your thoughts are, about the potential that we'll live in a world in the future where everything will be written by agents and it'll all be an APL. Well, my first thought is like that's almost the not opposite of what I've been seeing lately,
因为智能体将花更少的时间犯错并从这些错误中吸取教训。所以前提是像 Rust 这样的语言更适合智能体工作。并且我认为，如果这一切最终被证明是正确的，那么这就证明了我们所有人的正确——我们这些一直提倡抽象、泛型编程、函数式编程以及所有这些我们经常谈论、却遭到世人白眼的事情的人。总之，我很想知道你的想法：对于未来我们将生活在一个一切都由智能体编写、并且全都是用 APL 编写的世界的这种可能性，你有什么看法？好吧，我最初的想法是，这几乎不是我最近所见所闻的对立面，
but then again, the code that I've been generating has been code for authoring GPU kernels, of which no language like APL or J or K or Q or BQM has a good story for. And I'll find, I think I linked it before in the show notes, but someone once on LinkedIn DM'd me, or maybe it was Twitter, I don't know, some social platform, they messaged me a article that was talking about the most token efficient language is,
但话又说回来，我一直在生成的代码是用于编写 GPU 内核（GPU kernels）的代码，而像 APL、J、K、Q 或 BQM 这样的语言根本没有一个好的解决方案来处理这类任务。我发现，我想我之前在节目大纲里链接过，但有一次在 LinkedIn 上有人给我发私信，或者也许是推特，我记不清了，某个社交平台，他们给我发了一篇文章，里面谈到最高效 Token 的语言是……
and this was like half a year or a year ago. And at the time it was closure, and someone, there was like an update to the article that said a few people have mentioned, did you measure APL? And APL wasn't great because it was Unicode symbols, so it was like multiple, code points in a single graph theme.
这大概是半年前或一年前的事了。当时是 Clojure，然后文章后来有个更新，提到说有些人问：“你们测量过 APL 吗？”APL 的表现其实不太好，因为它是 Unicode 符号，所以一个字素（grapheme）里包含多个码点（code points）。
I don't understand unit code. Something like that. But then someone mentioned Jay, which is an ASCII-based APL, and Jay actually turned out to be much more token efficient than closure, which was the previous top one. Anyway, so those are my first thoughts. And then I can tell you more about the things I've been seeing. But like my newest thing is that I'm not actually sure.
我不懂 Unicode。类似这样的原因。但随后有人提到了 J 语言，这是一种基于 ASCII 的 APL，事实证明 J 语言在 Token 效率上实际上比 Clojure 高得多，而 Clojure 之前是排名第一的。总之，这就是我的第一想法。然后我可以告诉你更多关于我最近看到的事情。但我最新的看法是，我其实并不确定。
It depends on what you're trying to do. do. But for the thing that I've been doing, like, kernel authoring, it doesn't matter if you're starting with like pie torch, TensorFlow, Jax, Kupai, you know, or you're doing stuff in Kuta C++ at the thrust level, the cub level. Every single time I've put it into my like, agentic loop research project, it always ends up somehow writing Kudac C++. If it's Kupai, it invokes like Kupai dot rock kernel. If it's jacks. But see, so sometimes, sometimes that's okay at the end. So I did some experiments last week of comparing kernel authoring with high-level abstractions like Kutai or Triton versus like where I run some experiments for this.
这取决于你到底想做什么。但对于我一直在做的事情，比如内核编写，无论你是从 PyTorch、TensorFlow、Jax、CuPy 开始，还是在 Thrust 级别、Cub 级别使用 CUDA C++，每次当我把它放进我的智能体循环研究项目时，它最后总会以某种方式写出 CUDA C++ 代码。如果是 CuPy，它就会调用类似 `cupy.raw_kernel` 这样的东西；如果是 Jax……但你看，有时候，有时候最后这样也行。所以上周我做了一些实验，比较了使用高级抽象（如 CuPy 或 Triton）编写内核，与运行其他一些实验的差异。
There's this GP modes, this community that's very into GPU programming and they run these programming contests. and they had one last week for a dense-batched QR factorization. And so I submitted a bunch of, you know, agentic solutions to it. But then I also did some, like, experiments with that problem where I would run, I ran 12 experiments and, you know, with, where each one ran for like eight hours. And in half of the experiments, I said use higher level abstractions. And in the other half, like right kernels with high-level abstractions like Triton and Kutile, etc. And the other half, I just gave the guidance of write kernels using Kuta C++.
有一个叫 GP-MoDEs 的社区非常热爱 GPU 编程，他们会举办各种编程竞赛。上周他们举办了一场关于稠密矩阵分块 QR 分解（dense-batched QR factorization）的比赛。所以我提交了一堆智能体生成的解决方案。但随后我也针对该问题做了一些实验：我运行了 12 个实验，每个实验运行大约 8 个小时。在其中一半的实验中，我要求使用高级抽象；
And what I found is that it got a higher speed up per token by the time it was done with the higher level abstractions. And when doing the analysis afterwards, the reason was that with the higher level of abstractions, you were able to focus more, or the agent was able to focus more on different algorithmic approaches, different techniques, et cetera, different numerics, et cetera. Whereas if you write the lower level code from the start, then you're going to be more consumed with all the low-level details. Now, I suspect if you ran this through to completion, if you said, I'm going to let this run forever, that yes, eventually, you know, inevitably coup to C++ would come out ahead.
而在另一半实验中，比如编写使用 Triton 和 CuTe 等高级抽象的内核。在剩下的另一半实验中，我仅仅给出的指导是：使用 CUDA C++ 编写内核。我发现的是，当使用高级抽象完成时，它每个 Token 获得的加速比更高。事后进行分析时，原因在于借助更高层的抽象，你能够更加专注于不同的算法方法、不同的技术、不同的数值方法等。而如果你从一开始就编写底层代码，你就会被所有这些底层细节所牵绊。现在，我怀疑如果你把这个流程运行到头，如果你说“我要让它永远运行下去”，那么是的，最终，无可避免地，CUDA C++ 可能会胜出。
However, maybe what that tells you is that you should start iterating in the high level of abstraction, and then when you reach a point where you can't get any more performance out of the high level abstraction, that in those critical sections, you drop down to a lower level of abstraction. And that's exactly the message that everybody who's been focused on high-level abstractions, on productivity programming paradigms, has been saying for years, which is that this lets you iterate faster. And now we have, like, concrete, quantitative evidence of that. So, yes, maybe in the end of the day,
然而，这或许说明了什么呢？这说明你应该从高层抽象开始迭代，而当你达到无法从高层抽象中榨取更多性能的瓶颈时，再在那些关键部分下沉到更低层的抽象。这正是那些专注于高层抽象、专注于生产力编程范式的人多年来一直在宣称的观点，那就是：这能让你以更快的速度进行迭代。现在我们有了具体的、定量的证据来支持这一点。所以，是的，也许到头来，
everything ends up being written in Kuta C++ or in C++, if you're just doing CPU programming, or that eventually, you know, maybe it's just it always ends up being handwritten assembly. But there's the question of how do you discover the right algorithm to write in handwritten assembly. And the best languages and paradigms for exploring different implementation strategies are the high-level abstractions, the productivity layers.
一切最终都会用 CUDA C++ 或 C++ 编写（如果你只是在做 CPU 编程），或者最终，也许它总是会归结为手写汇编。但问题在于：你究竟该如何发现正确的算法来用手写汇编实现呢？探索不同实现策略的最佳语言和范式，其实正是高级抽象和生产力层。
Yeah. I mean, it's a very, very interesting question. And I think the problems that I've, like the kernels that I've been authoring or having the AI authoring haven't been tricky enough. And so maybe that's why it's able to like drop. you know, down to Kuta C++. But yeah, I've, I have been, what is it the, what is the way to say this? My belief in higher level abstractions and the need for them has been like shaken significantly.
是的。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常有趣的问题。而且我认为我一直在编写或让 AI 编写的内核问题还不够棘手。所以也许这就是为什么它能够下沉到
And I guess that's the thing is right now what you're looking at is token efficiency. What I'm looking at right now is not token efficiency. It's just like you've gone past the, I guess, trying to find speed of light to. how to find speed of light using the best token, you know, per... But I will say... I will say something in your defense, which is when I originally started doing this work, I provided the guidance that we give to humans,
CUDA C++ 的原因。但是，是的，我一直在……怎么说才好呢？我对高级抽象及其需求的信念已经被大大动摇了。我想这就是重点所在：你现在关注的是 Token 效率。而我目前关注的不是 Token 效率。这就好比你已经超越了……我猜，是在试图找到如何用最优的 Token 效率来达到性能极限（speed of light）。不过我要说……我得为你的观点说句公道话，那就是当我最初开始做这项工作时，我提供了我们通常给人类的指导，
which is I said, start by using the libraries. Use the accelerated libraries because the libraries are usually going to have better performance than, you know, then you're going to be able to write. And I still believe that is true. And I still think, like, if your goal is to land a minimal and maintainable change, right, into like an actual real-world
也就是我说：从使用库开始。使用加速库，因为这些库通常会比你自己写出来的性能更好。我仍然坚信这一点。我依然认为，如果你的目标是将一个最小的、可维护的改动合入实际的生产代码库中，那么使用某个优化过的库的改动，比添加一万行定制编写的代码要容易得多，也更容易长期维护。所以这里存在一个优先级的问题。如果你试图将某些东西合入实际的生产代码库，那么“优先使用库”这一指导原则依然成立；如果它们的性能不够好，然后再开始编写底层代码、手写优化代码（或者“手写优化”这个词现在已经不太准确了，
production code base, like a change that uses some optimized library is a lot easier to land and maintain over time than a change that adds 10,000 lines of bespoke written code. So there is a question of priority. If you're trying to land something in an actual production code base, then I think that the guidance of use libraries is, like, use libraries first, and then if they don't give good enough performance, then start to write low-level code, right hand-optimized code, or maybe hand-optimized is the wrong word now.
你知道我的意思）。但如果你是在参加某种编程竞赛，你的目标是为某个任务编写出运行速度最快的算法，那么我不知道你是否应该从库开始。你应该使用的是那些面向性能的高级抽象，比如 CuTe、现代 C++ 等——这些语言仍然专注于性能，但同时能为你提供高生产力和高表达力。除此之外，我认为你可能需要优先考虑的
You know what I mean. But if you're competing in some coding contest where your goal is to write the fastest possible algorithm for something, then I don't know if you should start off with libraries. What you should use is high-level abstractions that are performance-oriented. So things like Kutail, things like modern C++, things where it's still focused on performance, but it gives you high productivity and high expressivity. And then the other thing is, I think the type of library that you might,
库类型也会有所不同。构建模块（building blocks）比完全成型的现成解决方案更有用。这对于内核编写来说尤其如此，但我认为对于广泛的领域大概也同样适用：拥有能够提供高性能或高正确性（无论你的应用重点优先考虑什么）的可组合构建模块的库，在当今这个时代，要比拥有那种仅仅能作为非常容易直接替换的、针对特定任务的单体替代方案更加重要。因为现在有了这些能够为你量身定制解决方案的智能体。而拼凑出一个定制解决方案，
need to prioritize is different. That building blocks are far more useful than fully baked solutions. And this is particularly true for kernel authoring, but I think it's also probably true for a wide variety of domains, that having libraries that give you building blocks, composable building blocks that can be pieced together that are high performance or high correctness, whatever the thing you're focusing on prioritizing in your application, is probably more important in this day and age than having something that's just like a very easy drop-in monolithic replacement that does like a particular task. Because there's these agents that can piece together a custom solution for your particular needs. And then piecing together a custom solution is probably the
只要它能以一种易于维护且易于理解的方式来完成，那大概就是正确的事情。是的，这一切都建立在一个信念或假设之上：人类将需要继续留在这些系统的控制回路（in the loop）中。不，不，不，不，我不这么认为，我不这么认为。有一件事我肯定在我的 GP-MoDEs 竞赛中注意到了：GP-MoDEs 的问题往往从一行代码的参考问题开始。随着时间的推移，你知道的，模型会让它变得越来越复杂，它会针对不同的条件提出特例（special cases）等等。很快，你就会得到 9000 行代码，分散在 Python 和 C++ 等语言中。
right thing to do if it can be done in a way that's easy to maintain and and easy to understand. Yeah, this is all predicated on the belief or the assumption that humans are going to need to be in the loop for these systems. No, no, no, no, no, I don't think, I don't think so. I don't think so. One thing I have certainly noticed in my GP mode competitions, the GP mode problems tend to start off with a reference problem that is one line of code. And then over time, you know, the model's making it more and more complex. It's, you know, coming up with special cases for different conditions, et cetera. And it's very quickly you end up with like 9,000 lines of code with split across Python and C++, et cetera.
代码变得越大，代码变得越错综复杂，智能体处理它的难度就越大。你知道的，是的，我不会去逐行看代码，
And the larger the code gets, the more convoluted the code gets, the harder and harder it is for the agent to work on it. That, you know, the, yeah, I'm not going to look at the code. but I still care about how complex the code is, because even if it's not a human that's going to look at it, there is still the question of maintainability, right? Like, that still matters. And this is why people keep talking about this idea of direct to binary, that, oh, in the future, programming languages aren't going to matter
但我依然关心代码的复杂度，因为即使将来看代码的不是人类，可维护性的问题依然存在，对吧？这依然很重要。这就是为什么人们一直在谈论“直接生成二进制代码（direct to binary）”这种想法：噢，未来编程语言将不再重要，因为模型将直接编写汇编代码。各位女士，各位先生，拜托，醒醒吧。在这个时代，没有人会去发布这样一个软件产品：
because the models are just going to directly write assembly. Guys, girls, come on, come on here. It lets, nobody's going to ship a software product. where it's the only artifact is purely assembly code in this day and age. I know that it used to happen in the past, and there's special cases, but nobody's going to go and ship a desktop app, you know, that's written entirely in assembly. And the reason is simple is, sure, maybe that's going to work great the first time, but then what happens when you need to add a feature to it, when you need to change something?
其唯一的产物纯粹是汇编代码。我知道过去确实发生过这种情况，也有一些特殊案例，但没有人会去开发并发布一个完全用汇编语言编写的桌面应用程序。原因很简单：当然，第一次运行可能效果很好，但当你的软件需要添加新功能、需要做任何更改时，会发生什么呢？
It's going to be a nightmare. air. It might pop you out a perfect binary the first time, but as soon as you need to grow and evolve that software, like software evolution, software life cycles will still matter. And all the things that were applicable to software maintenance for humans will be applicable to software maintenance for robots. I mean, maybe. I don't, the confidence with which you say that statement is like, just reminds me of the hubris of humanity. And I think that there's a ton of people out there every time you mention the word intelligent with respect to LLMs, you know, there's a number of comments and messages that I get either on the GitHub discussions that say, you know, these systems aren't intelligent. And I just, like, there's this great podcast episode on the big technology podcast where they had a conversation with Jeff Hinton, the interviewer there, Kantrowitz, I think his name is.
那将是一场地狱般的噩梦。它第一次可能会给你蹦出一个完美的二进制文件，但一旦你需要让这个软件生长和演进——软件演进和软件生命周期仍然至关重要。所有适用于人类软件维护的原则，同样适用于机器人的软件维护。我是说，也许吧。我不认为……你说话时那种充满自信的语气，简直让我想起了人类的傲慢。而且我认为，每当你提到大语言模型（LLM）时用“智能”这个词，外面就有成千上万的人……你会收到大量的评论和私信，无论是在 GitHub 讨论区还是哪里，都在说：这些系统根本不具备智能。我就觉得，在 Big Technology 播客上有一期非常棒的节目，他们与杰弗里·辛顿（Jeff Hinton）进行了对话，采访者好像叫坎特罗维茨（Kantrowitz）。
And basically there's this, like Hinton mentions at a certain point in the podcast that there's like, like these times in history when like the ego of man is challenged at one point. Like I'm not a student of history, so I'm going to get this stuff wrong. But like at one point we didn't think or we thought that Earth was the center of the planetary system. And then Galileo or some other guy came along and said, no, it's the sun. But it took like 100 years. It took like 10 decades for people to accept that.
基本上，辛顿在播客的某个时间点提到过，历史上总会有这样一些时刻，人类的自我是受到挑战的。比如我不是个历史学者，所以我可能会把这些细节搞错。但比如在某个时期，我们并不认为——或者我们曾认为地球是行星系统的中心。然后伽利略或其他什么人出现了，说：“不，太阳才是中心。”但这花了整整 100 年。这花了整整 10 个十年的时间人们才接受这一点。
And it was like considered heresy. And there was a couple other examples when. like this, this kind of like, either like theocracy was challenged or man was challenged. And it took like, it took years for society to accept that like, oh, maybe, maybe this is the case. And like, I completely agree with Hinton that we're at one of these like points in history where, where people think that like, oh, you know, it doesn't think like us. It's just token generation. And I just like, whether, whether this, you know, whether LLMs are the incarnation of like beginning of like a. new, sentient, like, I don't want to say species, because people are going to freak out,
这甚至被认为是异端邪说。还有其他一些例子，比如这种神权政治受到了挑战，或者人类自身受到了挑战。社会花了数年时间才终于接受这一点：“哦，也许，也许事实确实如此。”我完全赞同辛顿的观点，我们正处于历史上的这种时刻之一：人们认为“哦，你知道的，它思考方式和我们不同，它只是在生成 Token”。我只是觉得，无论是……无论大语言模型是否是一种全新的、具有感知力的——我不想用“物种”这个词，因为人们会吓坏的，
but just like, whether it's LLMs or it's going to be like the sixth, you know, evolution of LLMs that will be called something else because it's not going to be like the transformer that is the basis of this technology. Anyways, I just like, when you say that we're not going to produce an artifact, I agree. I am, I have an ego and it makes me think that, like, of course we want something that is understandable by humans, but like, why does it need to be? What if we just have like a... I'm explicitly saying it doesn't have to be understanding.
而仅仅是……无论是大语言模型，还是未来被称为其他名称的第六代大语言模型，因为它不会再是作为这项技术基础的 Transformer 架构了。总之，我只是觉得，当你宣称我们不会再产出某种人工制品时，我承认，我也有自我意识，这让我觉得“我们当然想要某种人类能够理解的东西”，但为什么非要这样呢？如果我们仅仅拥有……我明确说过，它不需要让人类理解。
You just said guys, girls, why would you ship an artifact? Like, come on. You said guys, girls, come on. No, no, no. But my point is that nobody's going to ship software that is very difficult and very expensive to maintain. And if you produce... Who says it's difficult to maintain if we're not maintaining it? What if we, what if like, you know, some company comes along builds basically like an amorphous, like entity that, like that is the product, you know?
你刚才明明说：“各位先生女士，怎么能发布这样的人工制品呢？拜托。”你刚刚说过“各位先生女士，拜托”。不，不，不。我的观点是，没有人会去发布一个极其难以维护且维护成本极高的软件。如果产出的……谁说如果我们不维护它，它就难以维护了？如果我们……如果某个公司出现，从根本上构建了一个类似无定形实体的东西，而这个实体本身就是产品呢？
It monitors crime or something. I think that directly, directly writing and modifying today's executable binary formats is not the, the, is never going to be the right way to maintain durable software artifacts. Like what precludes it for being, you know, I was just. talking with Michael about this. Like, why does it why? Because executable binary formats are just simply not designed for this. Like, what do you design? Design, design for what? Like, for one,
它负责监控犯罪或其他什么。我认为，直接编写和修改当今的可执行二进制格式，绝不会是维护持久软件人工制品的正确方式。比如，是什么阻碍了它……我刚才正和迈克尔讨论这件事。为什么它……为什么不能？因为可执行二进制格式根本就不是为此设计的。比如，你设计的是什么？设计是为了什么？一方面，
if you need to, if you need to change like one aspect of a binary, it might require you to move around a significant amount of data elsewhere in the binary to like, like if we're talking about actual like direct to like an elf binary, like if you're adding a new function somewhere,
如果你需要修改二进制文件的某个方面，它可能会要求你在二进制文件的其他地方移动相当大一部分数据——比如当我们讨论真正的直接操作 ELF 二进制文件时，如果你要在某处添加一个新函数，
that might require you to rebuild like a whole, you know, symbol table or something or like redo all of the relocations. So you can make a tiny change to a binary that actually requires like a, or a tiny functional change that requires a huge, massive, actual change to the binary code. And so I can't imagine that that will be the level that people will operate at. Will there be more high level, will there be more programs expressed in terms of high level, IRs, like MLIRs, probably. I could buy that. But I don't think that we're going to be free from the deterministic software piece parts of it. And in fact, in fact, the best uses of AI, I think are these combinations of deterministic software, traditional software, and
那可能会要求你重建整个符号表之类的东西，或者重做所有的重定位。所以你对二进制文件做了一个微小的改动，实际上却需要对二进制代码进行巨大、海量的实际修改。因此我无法想象人类会停留在这种操作层级。会不会有更多高级的、用高级中间表示（IR）表达的程序，比如 MLIR？可能会。我认可这一点。但我认为我们不会摆脱确定性的软件组件部分。事实上，事实上，人工智能的最佳应用，我认为正是这种确定性软件、传统软件的结合。
intelligent software. And you mentioned a lot of listeners question whether these things have intelligence. I do not think that intelligence is the important attribute of these LLM systems. I think there's three key elements that make them uniquely capable pieces of software. The first is the self-healing nature that, or maybe they're put it in another way. The first is that they're flexible, that they are by their nature flexible to the environment that they're in and the instructions that they've been given. And this flexibility comes in part from the non-determinism of these models. The second is that they're self-healing. So if something goes wrong, they can assemble a way out of it, not always successfully, but they can assemble a way out of it beyond the circumstances that was imagined
智能软件。你提到很多听众都在质疑这些东西到底有没有智能。我认为智能并不是这些大语言模型系统最重要的属性。我认为有三个关键要素使它们成为了独特功能的软件。第一种是自我修复的性质，或者换一种说法。首先，它们是灵活的，它们本质上能够适应自己所处的环境以及被赋予的指令。这种灵活性部分来自于这些模型的非确定性。第二点是它们具有自我修复能力。因此，如果出现问题，它们可以拼凑出一条出路，虽然并不总是成功的，但它们可以在软件设计时未曾设想的情况下拼凑出一条出路
when the software was designed. And then the third principle is that they're autonomous, that they're not only capable of self-healing, of flexibility, but they do have some decision-making mechanism that can allow them to act without needing a human's input. And I think the question of whether they're truly intelligent, whether they're truly thinking or not, that I don't think is as important as the question of, like,
。然后第三个原则是它们是自主的，它们不仅具备自我修复和灵活性，而且确实拥有某种决策机制，能够让它们在不需要人类输入的情况下采取行动。我认为关于它们是否真正具备智能、它们是否真的在思考之类的问题，其实并不如这样的问题重要：
what can the technology do? and I think those are the three properties that make them very, very useful. And part of the nature of the current AI technology that we have and probably all future AI technology is that it is non-deterministic. It's not always reproducible. But that's okay because you compare it with reproducible, deterministic traditional software. You know, like I had a skill to, like, export and backup all the data on, VMs that I'm using. And I could just write the skill, but if I do that, then I'm not,
这项技术能做什么？我认为正是这三个特性使它们变得非常非常有用。我们现有的AI技术以及未来可能所有的AI技术的本质之一，就是它是非确定的。它并不总是可复现的。但这没关系，因为你可以把它与可复现的、确定的传统软件进行比较。你知道的，就像我有一个技能，可以导出和备份我正在使用的虚拟机上的所有数据。我可以直接编写这个技能，但如果我这么做了，我就不会，
the backup's not going to always be in the same format necessarily. It's maybe going to have slightly different names every time, et cetera. I could just write a script to do the backup. But if I just write the script, then, you know, the script could miss something. Or what if the script, I'm running the script somewhere and what if there's a bug in the script? Or what if, you know, I'm out of disk space or it can't reach, you know, the place that I'm doing the backup. to, then the script just fails. So the thing that's most useful, the thing that I ended up building, was a combination of traditional software and instant software, the AI, just prompting, etc. And that's to have, you know, I have some core script that I use for the export, but then I have
备份的格式不一定总是相同的。每次的名字可能会略有不同，诸如此类。我本来可以只写一个脚本来做备份。但如果我只写那个脚本，那么，你知道的，脚本可能会漏掉一些东西。或者如果我把脚本运行在某个地方，而脚本里有Bug怎么办？或者如果磁盘空间不足，或者连不上我用来备份的目标位置怎么办？那样脚本就会直接失败。所以，最有用的、我最终构建出来的东西，是传统软件与即时软件（AI、提示词等）的结合。也就是，你知道的，我有一些用于导出的核心脚本，但同时我也有
a skill that drives that script and that does a scan of its own and looks for anything that was missing and has a way to add, you know, any missing files to that backup if needed. And so I think those are the things that are most powerful today. And maybe in the future, it will be that we truly won't need any deterministic software. But I'm just, I'm not, I find that hard to believe because, one, the economics of deterministic software are just so much better than of everything being AI, at least today. Token costs would have to go down 10,000 X for that not to be the case. And two, there's something to be said for reproducibility. I agree with a lot of what you just said.
一个驱动该脚本的技能，它会进行自己的扫描，寻找任何丢失的东西，并在需要时将任何丢失的文件添加到该备份中。所以我认为这些是当今最强大的东西。也许在未来，我们将真正不再需要任何确定性的软件。但我只是，我只是觉得这很难相信，因为第一，确定性软件的经济效益比一切都是AI的好太多了，至少在今天是这样。如果不这样的话，Token的成本必须下降10000倍。第二，可复现性也有其价值。我非常赞同你刚才说的话。
I think future systems are going to boil down to deterministic scripts that are written by non-deterministic scripts and then like the non-deterministic LLMs. Or I shouldn't say non-deterministic scripts. Like you're going to have your deterministic computing, which is just, you know, Python scripts, choose your language, whatever. But then you're going to have your, you know, clod skills, non-deterministic things that are LLM functions. And the more you can push stuff into deterministic. scripts the better. That's what linting is. That's what evals are. You know, you know, you build loops around that stuff, fantastic. But I just, when I think about, like, what an LLM is, you know, it's ultimately like, you know, with a bunch of pre-training, post-training, all this fancy bells and whistles,
我认为未来的系统将归结为：由非确定性脚本编写的确定性脚本，以及非确定性的大语言模型。或者我不该说非确定性脚本。就像你会有你的确定性计算，也就是Python脚本，随便选什么语言都行。但接着你也会有你的Claude技能、非确定性的东西，也就是大语言模型函数。你越是能把东西推向确定性的脚本，效果就越好。这就是代码检查（linting）的作用。这就是评测（evals）的作用。你知道的，如果你围绕这些东西构建循环，那就太棒了。但我只是，当我思考大语言模型是什么时，你知道的，它归根结底就像，你知道的，经过了一堆预训练、后训练、所有这些花哨的装饰，
but it started out as just like a transformer, you know, and token generation. What is to say that, like, right now, we're building these LLMs that can generate Kudacet++ code and Python code, etc, etc. and there's linting and there's static analysis and we're building more and more guardrails which is a part of the reason that all of this stuff is getting so good if you play around with Claude Opus 4.8 you can look in the traces and they're all constantly if you're in Python
但它最初只是像一个Transformer，你知道的，以及Token生成。有什么理由说，就像现在，我们正在构建能够生成Cuda C++代码和Python代码等等的大语言模型，并且有代码检查、静态分析，我们还在构建越来越多的护栏——这也是所有这些东西变得如此优秀的部分原因——如果你试玩过Claude Opus 4.8，你可以查看追踪日志，它们一直在，如果你在使用Python
they're running rough and they're fixing things that it goes like there's so much so much of the stuff that like if you were using these models a year ago before the big jump back in December of 2024 you had to manually like you know add that stuff to your own loop in order to get good results.
它们一直在运行并修复各种问题，以至于如果你在一年多以前（也就是2024年12月那个大飞跃之前）使用这些模型，你必须手动将这些东西添加到你自己的循环中才能获得好的结果。
That's all baked in now. And my point being is, what is, what is preventing these models other than the bias of humans to like be, like, you know,
现在这些都内置好了。我的意思是，除了人类的偏见之外，是什么在阻止这些模型像，你知道的，
the rule of six that, you know, our brains are capable of storing like, you know, six or seven plus or minus concepts in our head at the time, which is why functional programming
“六的法则”那样——我们的脑海里一次能够存储大约六到七个（正负一）概念，这就是为什么函数式编程
and array programming, you can get further with it. You know, what's to say that like, that's not a limit. Like, you know, sure, LLMs have context windows
和数组编程能让你走得更远。有什么理由说这不是一个限制呢？当然，大语言模型有上下文窗口
and they have their own limitations but like what's to say that you couldn't take, you know, assembly code or P-Tex or SaaS and like train a bunch of really large language models build the same kind of linting tools which doesn't even make sense for us because like we program in programming languages, not in ones and zeros. But I'm just like I'm not convinced at all. Like I'm very skeptical. So I'm on actually your side.
并且它们有自身的局限性，但有什么理由说你不能拿汇编代码、P-Tex或SaaS来训练一堆真正的大语言模型，构建同类代码检查工具呢？这甚至对我们都没有意义，因为我们是用编程语言编程的，而不是用零和一。但我只是——我一点也不确信。我非常怀疑。所以其实我站在你这边。
Like I don't think that the future systems are going to be generating binary or executables. But that being said, I'm not like, I also thought the abstractions were going to be super important. And like I've seen now in some tests that I've run that like they, these models just, if you ask it for speed, it finds a way to basically invoke Kudu C++ at the end of the day, whether it's like FFI through jacks and a shared object file or like embedded like Kudac++ in a string in a Koo Pi like rock kernel or like anyways, it always finds a way to do like the fastest thing, which is in Kudu Kutu K++. and like it just discards all of the abstraction. Anyway, so if you take that to an extreme, you know, where do you end up? Do you end up in K2C++? Do you end up in P-Tex? Do you end up like in ones and zeros?
就像我不认为未来的系统会生成二进制文件或可执行文件。话虽如此，我并不是说……我也曾认为抽象层会超级重要。就像我现在在一些测试中看到的那样，如果你要求速度，这些模型最终总能找到方法去调用Cuda C++，无论是通过JAX和共享对象文件的FFI，还是像在Koo Pi的Rock内核中将Cuda C++嵌入到字符串中，不管怎样，它总能找到方法去做最快的事情，也就是Cuda C++，然后它直接抛弃了所有的抽象。总之，如果你把这一点推向极致，你会走向何方？你会走向Cuda C++吗？你会走向P-Tex吗？你会走向零和一吗？
I don't know. But I would argue the, it depends on what you mean by fastest. A higher level representation that's tunable, something like a kutile kernel, is going to be faster across the world of every possible. input that you could test. It's going to be a faster way to generate the correct, to Jit compile the correct algorithm for the particular input in conditions that you're currently running in. A lot of the problems, you know, there's a lot of talk about reward hacking, and I think you and I have talked about that in the past and how a lot of our efforts should be focused on
我不知道。但我会认为，这取决于你所说的“最快”是什么意思。一个可调整的更高层表示，比如一个Kutile内核，在你可以测试的所有可能的输入世界中，它都将是更快的。对于你当前运行的特定输入和条件，它将是生成正确的、JIT编译出正确算法的更快方式。很多问题，你知道的，有很多关于奖励攻击（reward hacking）的讨论，我想你和我过去也讨论过这一点，以及我们的很多精力应该集中在
reward hacking. But the other challenge with a lot of this like auto-optimization work is you can only benchmark for so many inputs. One thing I've been working on has been optimizing, you know, Cubs histogram. And I did a bunch of auto research with, you know, Cubs histogram benchmarks, which runs for maybe 10 minutes. If you want to test a representative set of inputs for histogram across a representative number of bin counts, number of element counts, data types, different input structures, you know, different like, like, you know, not just completely random, but different like structured input, you know, because that's what you'd see in the real world. It takes hours. It takes hours and hours and hours. You can't have an iterative loop that is
奖励攻击上。但这种自动优化工作的另一个挑战是，你只能对有限的输入进行基准测试。我一直在做的一件事是优化Cubb的直方图（histogram）。我用Cubb的直方图基准测试做了一堆自动研究，运行时间大约是10分钟。如果你想为直方图测试一组具有代表性的输入，涵盖各种有代表性的Bin数量、元素数量、数据类型、不同的输入结构，你知道的，不仅是完全随机的，而是不同的结构化输入，因为这正是你在现实世界中会看到的，这需要几个小时。需要数小时、数小时又数小时。你不可能拥有一个
that is writing truly generic performance portable code with this like tight, keep, commit, keep and revert process. You, I think a lot of what we're seeing right now with people doing this, you know, loop for optimization is writing really good code for a very specific circumstance. The process of taking that and generalizing it to something that can be deployed in production is a different story. It's still an agentic process. It's just, it's not, you know, these type iterative things.
通过这种紧凑的“保持、提交、保留与回退”流程，来编写真正通用、性能可移植的代码的迭代循环。我认为我们现在看到的很多进行这种优化循环的人，其实是在为非常具体的情况编写非常优秀的代码。将其拿来并推广到可以部署到生产环境的东西，那是另一回事。这仍然是一个智能体（agentic）过程，只是它不是那种迭代循环。
loops. You use those to explore and find techniques, and then you have to do some follow-on process to actually develop the algorithms that you're going to ship in production. And you have to deal with the trade-offs of accuracy, of, you know, code complexity, of the size of the binary that you're shipping, et cetera. Yeah. I mean, like I said, at the end of the day, I'm on your side. Like, I do think, I would be very, well, I would be surprised to a certain extent if, like, the best AI systems in the future are generating, you know, executables and binary. That being said, I don't know, I've, my wife has started to say that, like, I've, I've gone a little bit existential over the last, like, a couple weeks because the latest models,
循环。你可以用它们来探索和寻找技术，然后你必须进行一些后续过程，来实际开发你要发布到生产环境中的算法。你必须处理准确性、代码复杂度、你所发布的二进制文件大小等权衡。是的。我的意思是，就像我说的，归根结底我站在你这边。我确实认为，如果未来最好的AI系统在生成可执行文件和二进制文件，我会感到非常（或者说某种程度上）惊讶。话虽如此，我不知道，我的妻子开始说，在过去的几个星期里，我变得有点存在主义危机了，因为最新的模型，
they're just so good. And yes. And I've, I've started having, like, post-AGI thoughts. And I, at some point in this conversation, I was trying to think, in the trailer of a bad sci-fi movie in the last decade, it showed these like what looked like advanced servers and these like, they looked like they were self-healing. And I can't remember if they represent the like computation that runs society or something like that. At first I thought it was Jupiter ascending. But thanks to AI, I asked, it's like the instant free tier of Chad GPT.
它们实在是太优秀了。是的。我开始产生类似于后AGI（后通用人工智能）的想法。在这个对话的某个时刻，我一直在想，过去十年里某部烂科幻电影的预告片中，展示了那些看起来很先进的服务器，它们看起来好像可以自我修复。我记不清它们代表的是运行社会的计算还是别的什么。起首我以为是《木星上行》（Jupiter Ascending）。但多亏了AI，我问了一下，原来它就像是ChatGPT的免费即时层。
And sure enough, it nailed it. Well, it actually gave me like seven different options, but I recognized it as the last one. It's Valerian and the city of a thousand planets, which I'm pretty sure is based on a book. I recall this movie being terrible, but I'll, I'll share my screen and I'll find a way to tweet this out or something. Let me know if you can see this. Yeah. And so if we play this, it's only like a two second clip, but this scene right here, you know, we go back, you know, one second. This is what I think. this is like this is what I have started to think like where we're headed this is like computing in the future these are all like algorithms that are running
果不其然，它猜中了。好吧，它其实给了我大约七个不同的选项，但我一眼认出那是最后一个。是《星际特工：千星之城》（Valerian and the City of a Thousand Planets），我确信它是根据一本书改编的。我记得这部电影烂透了，不过我，我会分享我的屏幕，找个方法把这个发到推特上什么的。让我知道你们能不能看到。对。所以如果我们播放这个，它只有大约两秒钟的剪辑，但就是这个场景，你知道的，我们倒回去，你知道的，一秒钟。这就是我认为的。这就是我开始思考我们前进方向的地方，这就像是未来的计算，这些都是正在运行的算法
and these little guys that are like soldering stuff that's like that's like the self-healing it so when you say like oh we need to be able to inspect I don't think so I think we're going to have you know algorithms no no I'm not saying that I'm not saying that humans need to be able to inspect I'm saying that other agents need to be able to inspect yeah but how do you know that the language that they are most like efficient in is the same language that humans like evolved to understand. I don't, but I, but, but the current, the current technology that we use for AI are large language models that are primarily trained on human language text.
而这些小家伙就像是在焊接东西，那就像是自我修复。所以当你说“哦，我们需要能够检查”时，我不这么认为，我认为我们将拥有，你知道的，算法。不，不，我不是那个意思，我不是说人类需要能够检查，我是说其他智能体需要能够检查。是的，但是你怎么知道它们最高效的语言，会是人类进化出来能够理解的同一种语言呢？我不知道，但是，但是目前，我们用于AI的技术是大语言模型，它们主要是在人类语言文本上训练出来的。
There's a lot of interesting little fallouts of this. For example, I think almost everybody who's serious about auto research is running auto research in infinite loops. And one of the reasons you do this is that if you tell it to run for 24 hours, it's perception of how long it takes to write code is based on how long it takes humans to write code. And so it is just wildly inaccurate. It wildly overestimates how long it's going to do something. It'll be like, oh, here's a plan for how we can do something that's going to take two months. And you're like, no, we're going to do it tonight. And like, yes, maybe there are,
这里有很多有趣的小余波。例如，我认为几乎每一个认真对待自动研究的人都在无限循环中运行自动研究。你这样做的原因之一是，如果你告诉它运行24小时，它对编写代码需要多长时间的感知，是基于人类编写代码需要多长时间。因此它是极度不准确的。它极大地高估了它完成某事所需的时间。它会说，哦，这里有一个我们可以做某事的计划，这需要两个月。而你会说，不，我们今晚就能搞定。而且，是的，也许有
languages or intermediate representations that'll be better suited for these LOM technologies and the ones we currently use. I could certainly buy that. However, they are primarily trained on data that humans that we created, and they're primarily designed to interface with us humans. So I, just in the same way that like probably the most useful general purpose robot will be a humanoid form robot, simply not because that's the most efficient form, but simply because that's the world that we live in. We live in a world designed for humanoid-shaped things with machines and equipment that is humanoid-shaped thing, that's humanoid shape. Yeah, I do think that programming languages and programming models will evolve, you know, very drastically over the next few years.
比我们目前使用的语言更适合这些大语言模型技术的语言或中间表示。我当然接受这一点。然而，它们主要是在我们人类创造的数据上训练出来的，并且它们主要被设计用来与我们人类进行交互。所以，就像最实用的通用机器人可能采用人形外观一样，不仅仅是因为那是最高效的外观，而仅仅是因为那是我们生活的世界。我们生活在一个为人形物体设计的世界里，里面的机器和设备都是人形的，就是人形的。是的，我认为编程语言和编程模型将在未来几年内发生非常剧烈的演变。
But I don't see a fundamental paradigm shift away from the basic tenets of like software evolution and life cycles. Like I just, I find it hard to believe that we're going to be shipping elf binaries as the only software artifact. Maybe we'll come up with new binary representations or new types of computers or entirely new models. I could see that happening. But I think a lot of the things that make a computer system good for AI that make it agent-ready also tend to be the things that make it good for humans. Like, you know, having all your APIs, like, well-documented and, like, markdown,
但我没有看到远离软件演化和生命周期基本信条的根本性范式转变。我只是觉得很难相信我们将把ELF二进制文件作为唯一的软件工件发布。也许我们会想出新的二进制表示形式、新型计算机或全新的模型。我能看到这种事情发生。但我认为，许多使计算机系统对AI友好、让它为智能体做好准备的因素，往往也正是让它对人类友好的因素。比如，让你的所有API都有良好的文档并采用Markdown格式，
like, that's good for agents. It's also pretty good for humans, too. You know, like, if you're a human, you can go read a skill file. You know, I don't see a huge divergence yet in, like, away from, away from, I don't know, software maintainability. Yeah. What are we going to call this episode? And it's so sad, too, because I actually think this is like, this is like the most interesting
这对智能体很好。对人类来说其实也相当不错。你知道的，如果你是一个人，你可以去阅读技能文件。我还没有看到软件可维护性出现巨大的分歧。我们要把这一集叫什么名字？这也太让人难过了，因为我真的觉得这是我这段时间以来进行的最有趣的
conversation I've had in a while. And I feel like half of the people listening to us are just being like, these guys are out to lunch. Like, what drugs did they do before? That's okay. It's okay. I mean, we are very much at the epicenter. of this and we're to some degree like in an echo chamber, you know, maybe we'll be wrong.
对话。我觉得听我们说话的人有一半都在想：这俩家伙脑子瓦特了吧？他们录节目之前嗑了什么药？没关系。没关系。我的意思是，我们确实身处这场风暴的中心，某种程度上我们就像是在一个回音室里，你知道的，也许我们会错。
And not everybody has to agree with us and not everybody has to like it. However, I do think if you're a software engineer, you do have to be aware of what's going on. Because this is a big change to the way that your industry works. And if you're not at least aware, it's going to be very tough for you to remain relevant in this field. And so I think you got to stay abreast of what's happening. And this is one of the best places to do that, this podcast. Yeah. And I mean, yeah, I mean, some people think we're a little kooky. I mean, you know, but it's also like you think about, I think about my mindset on AI a year ago versus two years ago versus three years ago. And I was pretty skeptical too. And I see a lot of people
并不是每个人都必须同意我们的观点，也不是每个人都必须喜欢它。不过，如果你是一名软件工程师，你确实需要了解正在发生的事情。因为这对你所在行业的运作方式是一个巨大的改变。如果你甚至不了解情况，你将很难在这个领域保持竞争力。所以我觉得你必须紧跟时代潮流，了解正在发生的事情。而这个播客就是做到这一点的最佳场所之一。对。我的意思是，是的，有些人觉得我们有点古怪。我的意思是，你知道的，但这也是，你想想，回想我一年前、两年前、三年前对AI的心态，我当时也相当怀疑。我看到很多人
who are skeptical and I think they just really haven't. In some cases, it's not that they haven't tried it. It's just that sometimes it takes a little while to pick up and to really drink the Kool-Aid. And not everybody wants to. Not everybody wants to. That's the other piece of it. Not everybody finds it as enjoyable as we do. Yeah, I feel like drinking the Kool-Aid is the wrong aphorism for that, though, because that alludes to, you know, people that ended up dying. So probably people would find that. that they would be like, yeah, it is like drinking the Kool-Aid, but I feel like this is like, it's like Excel coming out as an accountant
他们持怀疑态度，而我认为他们只是真的还没有尝试过。在某些情况下，并不是他们没有尝试过，而是有时候需要花一点时间才能上手并真正“喝下这碗迷魂汤（喝下安利）”。并不是所有人都愿意。并不是所有人都愿意。这就是另一部分原因。并不是所有人都觉得这像我们一样充满乐趣。是的，我觉得“喝下安利”并不是一个恰当的委婉说法，因为这让人联想到那些最终死去的人。所以人们可能会觉得，
except that times like 100. And anyways, we got to stop. I would love to continue to chat, but I have to edit this. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
他们会觉得，是的，这就像是喝了迷魂汤，但我觉得这就像是Excel对会计师而言的意义，
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不过要乘以100倍。总之，我们得结束了。我很想继续聊下去，但我要剪辑这期节目。请务必查看这些shownotes（节目笔记），无论是在你的播客应用中，还是访问ADSP thepodcast.com，上面有我们今天节目中提及的所有内容的链接，还有一个GitHub讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下你的想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。